throwing snow
asks i'd love to know if chomsky
believes that cryptocurrencies can
really decentralize the financial world
and if that's even beneficial to society
at large
decentralization of financial
institutions
via cryptocurrencies or the
popularization of them well that's
i mean this is a question that arises at
many different levels
but one of them has to do with central
banks
the other has to do with investment
banks
banks all together you know so on
finance private financial institutions
central bank is essentially a government
institution though it's supposed to
function independently of the government
and these are different questions i mean
modern state capitalist societies
i don't think could function without
some kind of central bank
on the other hand the individual banks
have way too much power they're
probably harmful to the economy they've
grown
enormously in the past 40 years if you
go back to
1950 and 1960
first of all banks were tightly
regulated
and they were basically
closely connected to the real economy
a bank was a place where you could put
extra money if you didn't
want to use it right now you could go to
the bank for a loan to buy a car
you know things like that that's what a
bank was
not now after 40 years of neoliberalism
banks just have an overwhelming role in
the economy
there's a huge amount of trading that
goes on
which has nothing to do with the real
economy
in fact it's often and of course their
subject
continued crises and collapses
in fact they probably even couldn't
survive without a major public subsidy
the international monetary fund did a
study a few years ago of the top
the major us banks i think the top six
or so banks
and asking simply where does their
profit come from
it turns out their profit comes
overwhelmingly
from a government insurance policy
a policy that in
its public version is too big to fail
what it means is an implicit guarantee
by the government
that we're not going to let you collapse
because you're too big
that leads of course to regular
huge bailouts after a crisis
but much more than that it means the
banks have
access to cheap credit
they get inflated credit ratings
they can borrow on cheap terms they can
engage the investment banks can engage
in
risky activity which is quite profitable
in the short term and if it crashes
the friendly tax carrier will come in
and
bill them out so they have the numerous
advantages
that joined hard to put a number on them
bloomberg businessweek did an analysis
and estimated on the basis of the imf
figures that it would might amount to
maybe 80 billion dollars a year of
subsidy
that's a fair amount of money it's not
clear that
and more recent studies indicate that
financial institutions contribute to the
economy up to a certain level beyond
that they probably harm it
in many ways
it's pretty interesting that economists
have
not done very much study of this back
after the crash of 2008
2009 crash was caused by
predatory lending uh
methods of big investment firms and
banks
which were permitted by the deregulation
the massive deregulation of the
clinton administration robert rubin
lord summers others said you know
deregulate everything
which led to real criminal behavior on
the part of the banks
when it all crashed the government has
to step in and
yell them out it was the worst of
periodic crashes since reagan
there weren't many before because things
were controlled
there were some reflections on this
by leading economists i remember
an article by robert solo nobel laureate
economist very
smart guy in uh daedalus the journal of
the american
academy of arts and sciences in which he
raised the question whether the
financial
huge financial institutions are a
benefit or a drain on the economy
and he pointed out that economists had
given very little study to this
which is kind of striking because
especially over the
40-year liberal years they just become
an overwhelming part of the economy
but they didn't fit into the models that
economists were looking at
and he tried to give a
back of the envelope calculation and
concluded they're
probably harmful there's much more study
now which i think
gives greater weight to that conclusion
and there are many ways of cutting back
their
way massive oversized role
one very straightforward way is just the
financial transaction tax
small tax on every uh
financial interaction uh
doesn't it for the sum of money that
would be collected as
huge be a huge benefit to the
it goes right to the government which
could be used for productive purposes
for the bank and what it would do is
sharply cut back
uh trading that is irrelevant to the
economy
an awful lot of the trading that goes on
much of it automated by now
is just i can make a little bit of money
by moving something from here to here so
let's do it
there's nothing to do with the economy
enriches
various extraordinarily rich segments of
the economy
and all of that could be cut out just by
simple transaction tax financial
transaction tax
would move the financial institutions
closer to having something to do with
the real economy
but even beyond that it's a question
whether they shouldn't be broken up
why should they be bailed out every time
they crash why not break them
up if i want to put them under popular
control
why not have public banks and why not
have the post office
be used as a simple bank which people
could use because it's right there and
put money in it take money out there are
lots of ways of
cutting back on the extraordinary power
and
basically harmful role of these huge
institutions
i think those are steps that can easily
be taken
that should be nothing longer
you can ask what are these institutions
about all together but that
has to do with the nature of state
capitalist society
you